[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre le prince Président
nous a gratifié à leur méridienne de sa
bonne parole totalement hors sol il a
annoncé continuer à avancer à marche
forcée totalement hors sol il a osé
comparer l'un des plus grands mouvements
populaires de notre histoire à la
sédition factieuse des suprématistes
blancs envahissant le Capitole
totalement hors sol il a insulté les
manifestants et les manifestants sans
avoir un mot pour condamner les
exactions de la police qui sous vos
ordres tabasse nasse jette des grenades
en pleine tête roulent à moto sur les
gens intimides et arrête n'importe qui
n'importe quand sur le regard à l'armée
du Défenseur des droits totalement hors
sol et a plu à une incohérence près il a
tout de même reconnu que cette réforme
était brutale et surtout incomplète
qu'elle ne s'intéressait ni à la réalité
du travail ni à la pénibilité ni aux
fins de carrière ni aux reconversion
alors madame la Première ministre avec
gravité avec inquiétude nous vous le
demandons solennellement revenez à
l'hérélité et retirer cette réforme
avant d'avoir un drame sur la conscience